welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Spider-Man across the spider
versus most interesting and cryptic
character was spider Punk AKA Hobie
Brown a Spider-Man who speaks in you
could say code or if you're in the UK
you would just say he talks like you're
I guess your cool cousin talks and the
family's fighting on boxing day I don't
know you guys celebrate weird stuff over
there but for the rest of us I think we
can forgive ourselves if we missed some
of what he was saying when we watch this
but hey now the movie's on digital 4K
and we can really take our time and
decode all this Cockney wordplay the
more you look into the character of
Hobie is design everything he says and
does the more you realize this guy's
actually telling us everything we really
need to know why to distress the spider
society and everything that he's been
through before the events of this movie
and why we think he'll be the ultimate
hero of Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse as Hobie says oh this is
cool the whole time and by the way
sagaptra has informed us that
entertainment journalist like new rock
stars are allowed to continue covering
movies this way but we joined the unions
and calling to the studios and streamers
to make a fair deal with the
screenwriters and professional work
connectors and this video is sponsored
by Squarespace the all-in-one platform
that makes launching your own website a
breeze okay Hobie brown spider punk from
earth138 and that was confirmed by
Miguel's wrist device in the opening
sequence if you look closely he is
voiced by Daniel caluya who's originally
from Camden town in London one of the
birthplaces of punk music in an
interview with the voice newspaper
kaluya said that co-director Kent Powers
told him the characters should be real
and accurate to the black British
identity and punk way of speaking
are you sure I said yeah yeah yeah
some words may not understand that at
least that nah just but it shows that
their obsession with authenticity so
you'll notice throughout the film Hobie
speaks quickly and that plus the accent
plus a slang make him for anyone outside
the British Isles kind of hard to
understand which is what kaluya planned
for the character because at certain
points during the movie they do add
context on screen and what's that I
ain't got Scooby-Doo me because that's
what they want the words Scooby-Doo
Cockney rhyming slang for Cockney
rhyming slang works by taking a word and
rhyming it with some other word or
series of words to get your meaning
across like I ain't got a Scooby-Doo
means I don't have a clue a common
British phrase is apples and pears when
you mean stairs as in I saw her walk
down the apples and pairs if a plane is
flying overhead you might hear a
Londoner say there's a Tarzan and Jane
because Jane rhymes with plane sometimes
people won't even use the word they're
rhyming with and you just kind of have
to know from Context what they were
going to say and figure out what rhymes
with that this is often the case with
famous names so if you're gonna say
someone's having an arth or J you need
to know first off that that's a
reference to Arthur J rank the famous
1940s British industrialist and next you
need to figure out what the rhyme is
with rank so he was having an Arthur J
goes to he was having an Arthur J rank
goes to he was having a wank which is
British slang for you know
is it confusing yes yes is it cool as
hell also yes there their analyze the
cultural identity and yeah a bit of at
arm's distance snobbery that defines
what we love about the Brits now to give
a bit of historical context Cockney
rhyming slang emerged around the 1840s
when the EastEnders of London had to
make a living through various means some
of them illegal and needed a way to
communicate with each other in a code so
that the police wouldn't understand what
they were actually saying so it has
always been an anti-establishment code
speak and whoby in this film uses it the
same way to openly defy and contradict
the spider Society Authority in their
presence now where is Miguel O'Hara is
presented in this film as being all
about control and Order Hobie Brown is
the opposite he's pure chaos in the way
that he fights what he does what he says
he is sowing disorder but unlike Miguel
he actually is doing it for good and
stealing Tech from the spider society's
base of operations is something he's
doing for miles and for Gwen so that
Hobie can create an off-the-grid
interdimensional travel watch and get to
where he needs to go while it seems the
first thing he was just stealing just
for the hell of it there is a deeper
intention behind it just like everything
he says has a deeper layer of meaning
like the other spider people we've seen
Hobie launches into an explanation of
who he is and how he got there although
he starts off a bit differently because
he doesn't fit in with the establishment
or follow any of the rules all right my
name is Brian I was bitten by her man
after the last three years I've been a
one and only wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait I'm gonna show
you my secret identity come out of it
actually when he first arrives he says
is this the younger from 1610 now
younger is pretty easy to understand
even if you're not from across the pond
in British slang it just means anyone
younger than you and sometimes can be
used to mean a younger sibling
foreshadowing the brotherly
protectiveness Hobie will feel toward
miles later on causing him to help miles
on more than one occasion he talks to
him like a little brother having a
website is like having a business card
if you run a business you kind of need
one and that means you need Squarespace
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
that provides you with everything you
need to do whatever you need with your
website Squarespace says templates and
designs for every category and use case
so even if you're making your very first
website you in Squarespace makes it
super easy to customize your look update
your content and add features to fit
your unique needs if you're selling
merch Squarespace makes it easy to do
that too you can design your products
then save time and money by letting
Squarespace handle production inventory
and shipping and if you're selling any
other kind of physical Goods digital
Goods or even a service Squarespace
makes it easy to build your storefront
and grow your business to check out for
yourself head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain and
perhaps the coolest thing about the
character supervising animator Chelsea
Gordon ratsloves tweeted that hobie's
body was animated in threes but his
guitar best and outline were on
different frame rates twos and fours
collectively this gives them an overall
anarchic punk rock aesthetic he is out
of step with himself and out of step
with the other spider people different
parts of his body are rebelling against
other parts of his body now Hobe
speaking double entender's complicate
things even further because they add
more depth to everything he says for
example this stage an unpermitted
political action slash performing art
pieces or having a laugh at the pub with
Amanda at 8am I hate the p.m hate
neighbors I'm not a hero calling
yourself a hero makes you a
self-rphologized and narcissistic
autocrat yeah having a laugh at the pub
with Amanda means going to the bar with
friends or his crew and when he says he
hates the am and hates the PM it's some
wordplay meaning both the time of day
and hating the PM the Prime Minister and
as he says as he drags his boot across
an image of Kingpin which might be a
clue that in Earth 138 Kingpin was the
Prime Minister of that Universe now in
the comic spider Punk is an anti-fascist
anti-racist anti-establishment and at
one point he even led a revolution
against a tyrannical U.S government led
by President Osborne so there's also a
ton of nods to these character traits
and it's dialogue if he's listened
closely y'all make a heck of a team I
don't believe in teams aren't you in a
band I don't believe in consistency
crap on the establishment giving a movie
a re-watch just laser focused on Hobie
Brown makes me realize that everything
with him is just layers upon layers just
like how the character was animated but
just like stealing the text seemed
purposeless and erratic his language is
designed to be off-putting so that no
one can really understand what he's
saying until they think about it a bit
later so the characters who just brush
him off don't appreciate what he's
communicating to other people he's
trying to connect with he does not agree
with what Miguel O'Hara and a spider
Society are doing and he says the quiet
part out loud but no one gives a
enough about him to actually hear him
because with this chaotic look in his
language no one is paying too much
attention to him they just cannot
process him again like Daniel Kalia said
you might not understand him but there's
an authenticity to that and authenticity
that I think will pay off in the third
film when I believe he will come back to
fight alongside miles and the others to
take down Miguel in the spider Society
all right squashed
just don't enlist you know what war
you're fighting Hobie helps Gwen come to
that same realization about the spider
Society not being on the up and up and
he even knew before she did how
everything would go down I don't know
what it is you gotta do but I I think
that this thing is supposed to help the
guy who left it was a real piece of work
Gwen takes out the watch and in it is a
side note from a Hobie that reads in
case it don't work out so Gwen makes her
choice she's putting a band together and
she wants Hobie to be part of that band
this whole movie she's been looking for
a new band and right here is the lead
guitarist to compliment her chaotic
drumming in the final solo of the movie
want to close out with three more
important lines from Hobie that we have
to single out you're not a joke right
gang
happening
just kidding I love this because really
the joke here is in the dry pause before
I'm just kidding which is hilarious
because Hobie is really the first one at
the top of that chain so no one could
turn around and see his face and that
face would be masked anyway so it'd just
be impossible for anyone to tell if he's
being sarcastic or not which is just so
true for the Brits they love their dry
comedy they all understand their dry
comedy the rest of the world is like are
you kidding or are you not that's really
the widest point of the gulf in our
language barrier another important line
guys what's that
it's a metaphor for capitalism I love
this big
for British imperialism and Western
capitalism is something that Hobie Brown
and pop have in common these are the
kind of buildings that pop earlier
pointed to when he said this is where
the British stole all of our stuff he's
not referring to Hobie Brown he's
referring to the PM and lastly this
moments have you been on together oh not
that much the fact that Miguel had Earth
138 on his wrist that Gwen had already
had those green chucks at the start of
the movie that she got from Hobie tells
us that there is a history with these
characters one were Quinn and Hobie
caught Donald Glover Prowler together
and Hobie is the authentic hero that
Miguel is a pretender who has to use
technology who doesn't have spidey sense
Miguel can never understand and Hobie
Brown is going to be the hero that Miles
and Gwen can actually authentically
follow in the footsteps of now if you're
all excuse me I'll head to the Rub-A-Dub
for a pig's ear because I'm Adam and Son
yeah it doesn't really work as well when
I'm not actually staying in the accent
but I want to thank Gina ippolito for
writing this analysis researching the
history behind hobie's little word plays
and I also want to thank Paul from heavy
spoilers for his guidance on this whole
video project as our Nerd movie analyzer
across the pond please subscribe to
heavy spoilers doing great stuff over
there also please subscribe to all the
channels in the new rock stars Network
you can follow me on all social
platforms at eavos thanks for watching
I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]